hi leute ich wieder eure mal wanne und
ich würde sagen setzt playmobil
filmpalast fragt wie wär's mit diesen
typischen lieblings gabler fragen
ok lernst de coupe frack ist ja kleine
schwester m ist fragt ist ja cool ein
bruder ist jetzt eigentlich dein bruder
oder nicht weil das alles sagen stimmt
es dass du ja kuss schwester und
freundin bis das ist so kompliziert ist
froh du wirklich dein bruder wie alle
sagen was hältst du von fleisch wurst
tanja tee fragt was genau bedeutet
deinen tattoo am abend also eine
richtige bedeutung haben die jetzt nicht
wirklich
ich habe auf jeden fall diesen vogel das
ist ein origami vogel für die leute die
nicht wissen was es ist das ist ein
pinsel der ein herz malt und auf dem
rücken habe ich noch ein anfang mit
kirschblüten judith k fragt hast du
geschwister wenn ja verstehst du dich
gut mit ihnen
ja ich verstehe mich gut mit meinen
geschwistern ich habe eine schwester und
zwei brüder
sie haben uns alle ganz doll lieb paula
freut fragt hast du eigentlich so eine
vorstellung was du mal mit deinem kanal
machen möchtest oder möchtest du das
erstmal so weiter machst ich bin
eigentlich ganz zufrieden so wie meine
gerade läuft ich würde mir wünschen dass
ich natürlich immer
abonnenten erreichen aber das ist es
kommt gleich mit der zeit ich habe auf
jeden fall spaß bei wanne will's wissen
ich liebe es irgendwelche sachen
auszuprobieren und ich hoffe dass ich
noch coolere oder noch ganz verschiedene
sachen irgendwie hinkriege was ich in
zukunft vielleicht mal ausprobieren
möchte ist mehr so mädchenkram aber
jetzt nicht dass ich direkt in die
beauty spiel reingehen sondern einfach
irgendwie mal dazwischen so ein mädchen
mädchen ecke aufbauen
marie louise will wissen wie kommst du
auf deine video ideen alte andré es
glaubt doch kein mensch dass ich so auf
meine video ideen komme ich da etwas
neues
danke sany bunny fragt bist du beim
video day schrägstrich gamescom ja ganz
vielleicht bestimmt also ich habe auf
jeden fall lust und ich werde es auf
jeden fall versuchen kann es nur nicht
100-prozentig bestätigen
also wahrscheinlich schon sehr
wahrscheinlich und dann wenn uns da an
kann damit alle judith princesses sagt
wenn du zeit reisen könnten welche
zeitepoche würdest du reisen und
das ist eine sehr gute frage ich würde
es mir lange überlegt und dann habe ich
gehört dass die idee schon gibt aber ich
dachte ich bin erfinder dieser idee aber
das okay ich würde zu newtons zeit gehen
der typ der die schwerkraft erfunden hat
würde den apfel auffangen bevor er auf
seinem kopf fällt und dann gab es keine
schwerkraft heiß können alle fliegen und
das wird ziemlich cool und das wäre aber
niemals möglich malaga kuchen kuchen
aller gang kurven google fragt wie viele
traum kuchen kuchen malaga kuchen kuchen
fragt wie viel drauf malaga malaga
kuchen kuchen fragt wie viele trauben
sind die perfekte anzahl für eine
kartoffelsalat also bevor du mit dem
traum anfängst braucht halt erstmal
mayonnaise aber bei reese ist kein
instrument live live bild fragt wie
fühlst du dich wenn du fans triffst bis
jetzt damit zweimal passiert
beim ersten mal war alles cool da hab
ich mich gefreut dann zeig mal war ich
total verwirrt weil die personen haben
hat auf mich zu und meinte hey kannst du
ein foto mit mir machen und ich gucke
sie an total vergammelt und sagt nur
weißt du denn überhaupt bin ich an ja
sonst würde ich nicht fragen
was natürlich nicht fragen aber
irgendwie nehmen so ann kathrin mit abi
fragt was ist deine lieblingsserie of
all time
hanna meyer fragt könntest du dich
vegetarisch vegan ernähren was für musik
hörst du und hast du vor irgendwann
einfach einzurichten ich könnte mich auf
keinen fall vegetarisch ernähren weil
wer einmal in berlin war und die bürger
in berlin probiert hat weiß es nichts
besseres gibt als so ein richtig
schöneberger musik höre ich eigentlich
alles von relax zu kings of leon und
irgendwelchen 3+ alligator andere mimi
kam hörte ich wirklich alles und ja ein
postfach mitkommen wenn ich mich dann
irgendwann mal darum gekümmert hat dann
kommt johanna evers fragt wohnst du
schon immer in berlin
nein ich komme aus hamburg aber auch
immer so schlecht wetter da habe ich mir
gedacht zieht man nach belieben sind
coole leute ohnehin wenig einfach mal
hubert vanni liebt musik fragt wenn du
dein leben mit einem filmtitel
beschreiben könntest nie würde es heißen
ganz klar girl jetzt fakt bei mathe
hausaufgaben every single
day sarah und so fragt kannst du mal ein
video mit frodo machen und heute mit
einem special guest flora felix möchte
wissen wie bist du auf deinen namen
gekommen
den hat mir meine mama gegeben nein spaß
ich wurde früher war nie genannt mit 15
20 wann die dann richtig zum kotzen an
alle wann es da draußen tut mir leid ich
hasse diesen spitznamen wirklich so und
dann war meine coole phase dann haben
mich alle wanne genannt das habe ich
natürlich viel besser
und dann hatte ich in der elften klasse
ein praktikum bei einer lieben frau die
mit kindern gemalt hat und da stand ganz
viele mal wand und irgendwann habe den
geliebten aufgemacht für alle die es
nicht wissen eine mal wann ist eine
wanne wo alle mal utensilien reinkommen
damit du nicht den boden damit voll
klägers und ich halt schön ausleben kann
es mit lappen und becher und pinsel und
tusche und für alle die es interessiert
20 169 60 39 lasagne lacht gelb so leute
das war's mit dem faq ich hoffe er wird
spaß und wünsche euch eine schöne woche
wir sehen uns dann vielleicht mein video
day oder irgendwie beim nächsten video
wenn es darum geht andré